amo solo troppo contenta perché
ultimamente facciamo tutto insieme ci
siamo rotti separabili andiamo al cinema
insieme andiamo facciamo insieme andremo
insieme e andremo in montagna insieme ma
la cosa più importante che io so che di
te mi posso fidare ciecamente
perché tu non mi tenute rai mai perché
non mi hai mai e soprattutto non mi
abbandonerà mai mi sono fidanzata cosa
amo ma non cambierà nulla tra di noi e
che ci sarò sempre per te e poi ed
escono ma che sarà troppo simpatico anzi
aspetta è arrivato e qua sotto
non vedo l'ora di conoscerti e firmò
mensile the row eccoci molto piacere
edoardo e ricami ha parlato un sacco di
te immagino come dove vi siete
conosciuti comunità a complimenti sei
trovato un tossicodipendente brava ma va
cosa hai capito
ti ricordi lo sai che facevo in comunità
ecco lui fa il volontario
quindi sei disoccupato in realtà sono
ingegnere aerospaziale
le due lauree di cui una in psicologia
quindi tutto il tempo libero la dedica
al sociale portò cibo coperte senza
tetto o lite comunità
quello che posso quello sono scelto bene
vero un benissimo ragazze dopo aver
dimenticato il telefoni macchina torno
subito
non mi convince hai già superato sui
social si tranquilla lui è uno che non
pubblica niente questo lo dici tu chi è
questa sua sorella è questa qui cugina e
la bionda benissimo
erika e poi c'è il gas forse non
lasciate aperto vai a controllare ma dài
dài senti imbecille forse non hai capito
quella è la mia amica anzi e mia sorella
sei tu la tratti male io ti vengo a
prendere a casa e ti faccio tanto tanto
male perché sono vendicativa io non
perdono tutto bene
noi andiamo bene noi andiamo comunque
ricordati tra noi non cambierà mai nulla
va bene è stato un piacere
slater
[Musica]
e adesso sì che è a ciao erika dimmi che
fai stasera guarda sono molto impegnata
ultimamente si impegnatissima perché
volevo chiederti di uscire se non puoi
se ci sono appuntamenti li disdico
cinema domani devo svegliarmi presto
invece che ne diresti di una cenetta si
pensa hamburger pesante lezcano sai che
conosco un posto vegano buonissimo tira
di provarlo
va bene andiamo al vegano a dopo ciao
lo sapevo che non è moralmente casa le
migliori amiche sono così nonostante
tutto restano sempre unita amo non sai
quanto sono contenta di essere qui a
cena da sole io e te amo quanto tempo è
passato mi sei mancata tantissimo però
giuro ma io lo sapevo lo sapevo che lui
non era ragazzo per te io appena l'ho
visto ho capito che c'era qualcosa che
non andava ma l'importante è che tu
adesso sia tornata sui tuoi passi
l'importante che foresta si è libera
come un fringuello trama non hai capito
è data solo parcheggiando non ci siamo
lasciati sta arrivando ma come ci credo
amo meno male siamo innamorati quando
sai che una persona lo sai come stare
sempre in banale possibile ma state
ancora insieme ma non staccate un attimo
significati in simbiosi ma questa non è
vita
non lo so ci mancava mai mandato in giro
vestite uguali ma non è possibile non lo
so adesso mi portate anche l'amico
simpatico
ciao lui e luca bisogna vedere e dove ha
parlato tanto come immagino slater mani
che fine ha fatto
ma si fa più sentire chiamala fatto una
cenetta insieme tanti questa sera guardo
la partita
ciao amore ciao come stai
tutto bene tu bene grazie pensavo e cosa
fai stasera ti va una cenetta aiuta come
ai vecchi tempi
no no guarda non me la sento perché fai
non sto benissimo quindi preferiscono
uscire non prendere freddo magari
rimandiamo a settimana prossima no va
bene
fammi sapere allora va bene cerchiamo un
bacio già allora amore cosa guardiamo
film romantico o serie tv ma quello che
vuoi tu piccola l'importante è che tu
sia
[Risate]
[Musica]